interviewsperre Frau lau für wen gilti
also ich glaube die gilt in erster Linie
für die Aspiranten diejenigen die jetzt
die Partei übernehmen wollen also das
die fünf Bewerber um das Amt des
Parteivorsitzes vor allen Dingen die
aber ich glaube es gilt auch für alle
die jetzt sich mit Interviews auch nach
vorne gedrängt haben und gesagt haben es
darf kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen
bleiben gerade die sollen jetzt auch so
ein bisschen diszipliniert werden und
jetzt ist einfach Ruhe die erste
Bürgerpflicht und das heißt nur die
kritischen sollen keine Interviews geben
und deswegen da Frau man hier sitzen
weil er angenehme Dinge war eine Laschet
sagt oder was ist der Grund
nee ich glaube wie gesagt also der die
Parole ist jetzt
Kirche im Dorf lassen den Prozess
geordnet ablaufen lassen und jetzt nicht
alle aus der Reihe tanzen und vor allen
Dingen ist das Ziel die Aufmerksamkeit
auf die Ampel Sondierungen zu legen und
eventuelle Widersprüche da im
Vordergrund stehen zu lassen und nicht
immer die Union die sich zerlegt lass
uns sozusagen zu gucken wie die sich
jetzt so legen gehen Sie weiter es gibt
hier nichts zu sehen das ist großartiger
Satz das heißt sie dürften heute abend
jetzt eigentlich hier sein oder eher
nicht wir haben niemand gefragt und ich
bin auch überhaupt nicht angesprochen
worden ich gehen wo ich hingehen will
fertig aus ja finde ich gut sehr
sympathisch wer nicht fragt kriegt ja
auch keine Antworten es gibt eine
Anspruch gegen die zu deinen Herren wenn
du nicht gerufen wirst okay haben Sie
gewusst nicht gemacht weil sie Angst vor
der Antwort hat wussten sie von dieser
Sperre von dieser von dieser Ansage also
ich habe überhaupt nicht gehört dass ein
Sperre gibt ist doch klar dass immer
wieder in ein Partei gerieben und das
habe ich schon tausendmal gesagt wird
geht auch wieder an die Kameras vorbei
war ist ja auch dass die CDU zurzeit
nicht Alleinunterhalter der politischen
Zähne sein muss wenn auf der anderen
Seite spannendste politische Gespräche
stattfinden ist ja auch wichtig dass das
auch in der Öffentlichkeit klar wird
auch klar wird wo der Bruchstellen sein
könnten oder sind aber das ist jetzt ja
auch alles noch zu früh weil man ja aus
den Inhalten der ampelgespräche gar
nichts weiß ich mache das ja was diese
Frage angeht gut das muss man einfach
sagen anders als die CDU als die CDU
früher haben wir es auch schon mal so
gut gemacht ja nicht so sie machen das
einfach gut dass sie über die Inhalte
nicht reden aber wir kennen ja alle die
Parteiprogramme der drei die da
zusammensitzen oder wissen wir ja auch
dass es da durchaus Punkte gibt die
nicht so einfach übereinander zu bringen
sind und das aus unserer Sicht darüber
auch geredet werden muss ist ja klar
aber deswegen und außerdem ist das bei
der CDU auch zurzeit das muss man jetzt
einfach sehen wir haben uns ja
entschieden
richtigerweise dass 30 Oktober unsere
330 Kreisvorsitzenden eingeladen werden
und im Grunde genommen ist das Ergebnis
der bundesvorstandsetzung und des
Präsidiums ja das
so dass wir sagen diese und jetzt mal
sagen wie soll der Weg zu einem neuen
cdu-bundesvorsitzenden oder zu einem
neuen CDU-Bundesvorstand auf dem anderen
bleiben höre ich ja es gibt Leute die
das gesagt haben da habe ich nur gedacht
naja die Fundamente auf die die CDU
Städte sind über 2000 Jahre alt die
werden auch von diesen Leuten nicht
auseinander direkt von Jesus von
Nazareth direkt zu Armin lassen also
kein Stein auf den anderen bleiben in
der CDU heißt ja CDU ist ja mehr wie
Personen die zurzeit Ämter haben ja die
CDU ist eine christliche Volkspartei der
Mitte und das Wertefundament was wir
vertreten das wollte ich nur sagen und
das ist das Fundament auf dem diese
Partei steht
das ist doch schon ein bisschen älter
oder haben Sie Recht aber dafür dass sie
auf einem so zutiefst christlichen
Fundament stehen ging es ganz schön
unchristlich zu in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen bei ihnen finden Sie auf Ja das
ist wahr und man muss ganz einfach eins
sagen ich finde man muss immer
unterscheiden
die Angriffe von Herrn Söder die waren
ja immer so verpackt dass sie deutlich
machen eigentlich wäre ich der bessere
Kanzlerkandidat und daraus ist ja ein
ein Spin entstanden wie man das heute so
sagt das ganz viele das geschrieben
haben ganz viele das dann auch immer
wieder gesagt haben und am Ende
natürlich auch in der Bevölkerung manche
Leute gesagt haben naja ihr habt doch
einfach nicht euren besten Mann genommen
das hast du ja an den Wahlkampfständen
gehört
alle Schuld auf Söder oder nein ich will
gar nicht gerade Schuld aus Sylter sagen
denn man muss ja schon zugeben wenn ich
mir jetzt andere angucke die sich
vielleicht für
Ämter für geeignet halten die waren
natürlich im Wahlkampf schon solidarisch
also ich finde nicht dass man jetzt
sagen kann dass Friedrich Merz zum
Beispiel zu nennen im Wahlkampf eine
schlechte Rolle gespielt hat sondern er
hat das gemacht was er in diesem
Wahlkampf machen sollte und hat das
finde ich loyal zu Laschet gemacht finde
auch nicht dass man jetzt sagen kann
Jens Spahn habe ist schlecht überlastet
geredet das ist ja nicht wahr also man
muss schon auch bei dieser Frage ein
Bisschen bei der Wahrheit bleiben
sondern das waren dann ja eher Dinge die
wir einfach an der Basis haben ich meine
man kann es ja nicht leugnen wissen Sie
wenn ich dann sagen wir mal in anderen
Landesverband war ich habe im Wort
kannst du ungefähr 70 Wahlkampf Einsätze
gemacht so wenn du dann irgendwo kommst
dann fragst du wenn du kommst rein oder
sagst den Leuten na wie geht's dann
sagen die ja wenn wir Hausbesuche machen
und so euer Ministerpräsident das ist
hier nicht einfach zu verkaufen so wenn
ich jetzt den anderen Bundesländern
einfach zu verkaufen ist ja ein nicht
einfach zu verlassen
dass die Leute natürlich eine Haustür
unseren Wahlkämpfer gesagt haben wieso
soll der das Bundeskanzler werden so das
kann ich ja nicht ig immer wenn wir ganz
normale
cdu-leute irgendwo in Deutschland ich
will jetzt ganz bewusst gar kein
Landesverband nennen das sind ja keine
Leute die den Ansatz vorbeiführen nein
ja aber in fast allen Bundesländern also
ich kann Ihnen nur sagen das ist ja
einfach so dass das dann eine Stimmung
war wo die Leute sagen selbst Menschen
die eigentlich so vom Klientel unsere
Wälder sind die sicherlich in ihr Leben
auch ganz oft CDU gewählt haben haben
diese Fragen gestellt und deswegen bin
ich einfach der mal dass man heute sagen
muss aber in Vergangenheit bringt dann
ja nichts auch diese Kandidatur lag
schlicht und ergreifend von Anfang an
kein Glück den man am was man am Ende
auch braucht um es dann erfolgreich zu
Ende zu bringen anders muss man wieder
sagen hätte die CDU anderthalb Prozent
mehr hätten wir eine ganz andere Debatte
in Deutschland aber trotzdem kann
überzeugendes Ergebnis also ich meine
CDU unter 25 Prozent ist einfach
schlecht falscher Kandidat
also ich bin schon der Meinung dass man
sagen muss
ich frage mich nur ob das mit den
anderen Kandidaten besser gewesen wäre
und das ist jetzt eine Frage die kann
ich nicht beantworten
finde ich schon dass man sich fragen
muss ja klar dieser große Doppelpunkt im
Raum ja gut ich glaube dass das sich die
Frage auch selber stellt der wenn man
aus einer war so rausgeht wie wieder
jetzt rausgegangen sind muss man sich ja
auch ganz einfach diese Fragen stellen
ich weiß nur nicht und das sage ich auch
mal ganz offen ob jetzt der bayerische
Ministerpräsident der bessere
Kanzlerkandidat für die Partei gewesen
wäre
es hat er gute Gründe gegeben warum
Menschen wie ich zum Beispiel für
Laschet waren weil ich einfach der
festen Überzeugung war und bin dass er
das was CDU ausmacht
von seiner Person und von seiner Art her
gut vertritt denn wir müssen als CDU ja
immer eins denken
der CDU Vorsitze kommt immer ihr aus
irgendeiner Strömung in der Partei das
war bei allen CDU-Vorsitzenden so die
ich kennengelernt habe aber wichtig ist
ja für ein CDU-Vorsitzender das er weiß
dass die CDU mehr ist wie die Strömung
wo man selber herkommt
so die CDU ist eine sehr breit
aufgestellte Volkspartei wir müssen
selber sein ich sag mal für den
mittelständischen Unternehmer aber wir
müssen auch selber sein für den
Handwerker es ist ihre Aktien sie wollen
keine reine wirtschaftsparteien die sind
keine arbeitnehmerpartei aber sie sind
auch keine unternehmerpartei wir müssen
richtig erlauben man hat das ja nicht
wir müssen noch ein riesen Thema mit
Glaubwürdigkeit dieses Mal wir haben
dieses Mal das kann man ja ganz klar
sagen wir haben ja in allen Gruppen
verloren verloren Punkt also ist ja
nicht so dass wir jetzt die Wahl
ausschließlich bei Arbeitnehmer verloren
haben oder ausschließlich bei
Frauen verloren haben oder
ausschließlich bei wie auch immer
verloren sondern wir haben ja in den
gesamten Spektrum ganz schlecht
abgeschlossen so jetzt soll der
Neuanfang kommen da kommen diese jungen
Köpfe diese jungen Nachwuchstalente
Philipp Amthor und andere sagen wir
brauchen jetzt neue Empfang Thielmann
Kuban sie mir da beispielsweise auch wer
soll diesen Neuanfang gestalten
die in der CDU wer ist in der CDU an
unverbrauchter Kopf also ich würde es
mal so sagen
es wird niemand sein können der nicht
über eine gewisse politische Erfahrung
verfügt
ich glaube nicht dass jemand eine so
große Partei wie die CDU führen kann
wenn er nicht über gewisse politische
Erfahrungen und auch Lebenserfahrungen
verfügt kommt ja auch beides zusammen
man kann ja nicht mit 30 Jahren
beides haben ist ja unmöglich von der
Zeitachse also wird es jemand sein oder
eine Frau sein die mit Sicherheit schon
länger in der Politik ist und da ja alle
Namen
ob die jetzt selber alle kandidieren
wollen ist ja noch mal die zweite Frage
also Frau findet ihr genannt Frau welche
Frau fällt Ihnen ein wir haben zurzeit
finde ich also bei Frau sehe ich zurzeit
eben niemand so richtig
bei Männern wer fällt den da ein ja gut
weil die Männer sind ja die Namen auf
den Tisch die jetzt sich warm laufe ich
glaube schon dass es einer von denen
Röntgen am Ende werden wird es ist ja
das ist ja bekannter steht ja jeder
kennt ich helfe noch mal kurz klar Spahn
Linnemann ja bring Chaos ja das sind ja
die Namen die fünf Männer aus NRW ja wen
würden Sie wählen das wäre ich Ihnen
heute nicht sondern es geht ja darum wer
wird am Ende von sagen Sie mir wen sie
nicht wählen würden nein es geht ja also
ich sag nicht mal ganz offen ich glaube
einfach dass für mich ganz wichtig ist
dass jemand die CDU-Vorsitzende daran
gebunden ist
das ist ein Mensch sein muss der weiß
ich kann diese CDU nicht in eine
Richtung führen sondern aus Sicht eines
cdr-vorsitzenden muss die CDU eine breit
aufgestellte Partei wir sind nun mal
eine Partei die aus unterschiedlichen
Wurzeln entstanden ist das christliche
soziale ist eine glaube ich ziemlich
wichtige davon und ich will eine CDU
haben die keine Klientelpartei ist also
ich hatte das ja schon oft gesagt wenn
ich auf etwas stolz bin ist dass das die
CDU nie eine klientierpolitik gemacht
hat dann versuche es mal anders dann
Grenzen wir es doch mal ein Follower
helfen sie mir mal ganz kurz Herr
Laumann ist für den Mindestlohn
ungewöhnliche Position in der CDU hab
haben sie die Fantasie das Friedrich
Merz sich spontan für einen
mindestlohnerwärmen kann
spontan nicht aber ich glaube angesichts
der letzten Wahlergebnisse würde er dann
auch
alte Positionen Räumen ich meine der ist
auch nicht blöd der weiß auch dass was
jetzt passiert ist nämlich das die Union
an SPD und Grüne verloren hat und dass
man mit der Melodie aus den 90er und und
frühen 2000er Jahren das
Wirtschaftsliberalismus heute nicht mehr
so richtig weiter kommt das weiß der
März auch aber er steht natürlich in den
Augen der meisten Leute für diese Zeit
genau das heißt Friedrich Merz scheidet
aus für viele andere CDU-Basis nicht
also ich glaube die meisten die jetzt
sagen
mitgliederbeteiligung
mitgliederbeteiligung ist eigentlich ein
anderes Wort für Friedrich Merz die
meisten die sagen Mitglieder Fragen mein
März
das sind sie für eine
mitgliederbeteiligung ich bin bei
mitgliederbeteiligung und ganz kritisch
okay also er ist nicht für Friedrich
Merz nein nein also
vorher gegen Friedrich Merz und ab jetzt
also wir haben Entschuldigung wir haben
in Nordrhein-Westfalen gemacht da ist
Norbert und warum bekommen das dann auch
nicht die glückliche sehr gut
haben wir raus bleiben Linnemann Spahn
und Brinkhaus
sie nicken okay
also man muss sagen in Baden-Württemberg
die CDU in Baden-Württemberg liegt auch
deshalb am Boden weil sie eine
Mitglieder durch Mitgliederbefragungen
sich total gespalten hat die
mitgliederbeteiligung hat die Spaltung
total zementiert und die kommen nicht
wieder aus dem erfahrenen Mann wie Herrn
Laumann bleiben übrig Jens Spahn Ralf
Brinkhaus und Carsten okay Jan Spahn
schütteln Sie auch den Kopf okay
und herbrinkhaus also ich würde jetzt
mal sagen lass es jetzt einfach mal so
stehen sie werden keinen Namen von mir
kriegen und ich sage immer ganz klar
Leute
keine aufgestandenen was ist was ist das
ich meine damals ist Brinkhaus schon mal
aufgestanden also es ist gegen Volker
kauderging das einfach gemacht hat er
seine Truppen organisiert und hat es
gemacht ja hätte doch am Montag auch
machen können aber jetzt erstmal jeder
hat da sagt lass uns das erstmal diese
Kreisvorsitzenden Konferenz abwarten und
dann schauen wir mal weiter wenn man
sagt wir wollen in ein Gremium was
eigentlich dafür zuständig ist nämlich
der CDU Bundesvorstand das Verfahren
nicht bestimmen sondern wollen das in
eine Kreisvorsitzende Konferenz geben
dann ist das so und die
kreisversicherung Konferenz kann vor den
30 Oktober nicht stattfinden weil an dem
Wochenende davor dann
nordrhein-westfälische Landesparteitag
ist und natürlich anhand da wo ein
Landesparteitag ist nicht gleichzeitig
eine kreisrunde zu Konferenz stattfinden
kann deswegen dieser Termin und deswegen
gibt es jetzt diese zwei Wochen so
zu diesem Termin wo das Verfahren nicht
klar ist und ich würde als Kandidat
selbst wenn ich das also wenn ich mir
jetzt vorstelle was geht in jemand vor
der da gerne kandidieren möchte ich
natürlich das Verfahren kennen bevor ich
mich dazu äußern das heißt wenn
angenommen die Ampel Sondierungen die
die Klappen jetzt nicht fraulaut wen
ruft denn dann weiß ich nicht Christian
Lindner an er muss derzeit muss er
aminaschad anrufen und an wen verbindet
dann Armin Laschet ich glaube das hat
schon also das amila steht schon in der
Lage ist solche Gespräche zurzeit noch
zu führen effizient grundsätzlich auch
nicht alleine das tut ja kein glaube
dass Herr Laschet in der Lage solche
Gespräche noch zu führen ich bin fest
davon überzeugt dass er diese ja ich
meine jeder weiß dass
die Tage von die Zeit von Armin Laschet
als Bundesvorsitzender CDU zu Ende geht
es rein eine Frage ob es im Dezember
passiert als sie die Parteitag bis dahin
kriegen wenn wir eine
Mitgliederbefragung gehen wird der
Termin ja wahrscheinlich ein
vorweihnachtlich zu machen sein alleine
von den Zeitabläufen das ist ja nur
jetzt kein Geheimnis mehr
das Problem ist doch die Kommunikation
keiner sagt das die Frage ist
entschieden sagen sie
ist die Tage von Armin Laschet gezählt
sind also die Tage von Armin Laschet
sind nicht gezählt sondern die tare wo
einmal Laschet Vorsitzende der CDU in
Deutschland ist eine persönlichen Tagung
aber politisch macht und auch politisch
also anschließend ich hoffe dass eine
Laschet auch in unserer Partei wieder
einen guten Platz findet oder in der
politischen Arbeit ein guter Platz
findet weil ich glaube einfach dass er
ein guter Politiker ist Punkt
ganz kurz die CDU droht in einem
gigantischen in einer gigantischen
Murmeltier Wiederholungsschleife
festzustellen irgendwann mal das ist
genau das ja ich weil sie gerade gefragt
haben warum ist eigentlich am Montag
kein Aufstand Erfolg der ist deshalb
nicht erfolgreich
auf seine verschlungene Weise zu
erkennen gegeben hat ich habe verstanden
es ist vorbei dann das wird so ein
bisschen in Zeitlupe findet das statt
aber es war klar dass es einen Abschied
gibt und deshalb gab es keinen Aufstand
am Montag wenn er beharrt hätte dann
hätten sie ihn am Montag vom Hof gejagt
was ich meine jeder interpretiert das so
wie er will da ist ein unglaubliches
Vakuum entstanden warum stellt sich
jemand nicht irgendwann mal hin und sagt
einfach okay ich habe diese Wahl
verloren und ab jetzt geht es ohne mich
weiter ich kann das gerne auch noch
moderieren ich kann versuchen einen
Übergang hinzukriegen aber ohne mich als
Mann an der Spitze
das ist eben das das ist glaube ich am
Wahltag genau wie sie sagen das ist
direkt danach hätte man das machen
müssen und hätte man das auch in der
Fraktion machen müssen man hätte sagen
müssen okay Leute wir haben verstanden
wir haben jeden Regierungsauftrag
verwirkt ihr wollt uns nicht wir ziehen
uns in die Opposition zurück das hätte
man eigentlich machen müssen aber das
ist natürlich es geht natürlich gegen
jeden Instinkt einer alten Volkspartei
aber das wäre
der richtige Schritt gewesen und da man
den nicht gemacht hat bleibt man jetzt
im Modus des Kirche im Dorf lassens weil
ich wollte noch mal sagen diese
Einlassung am Wahlabend kurz nach der
Veröffentlichung der ersten trendmeldung
wo wir uns ja bewusst nicht aus den
ränden genommen haben für eine
Regierungsbildung die war im
Parteipräsidium abgesprochen das
Parteipräsidium hat sich um 17 Uhr
getroffen dann hat man so gegen 17 Uhr
weiß man auch so ein bisschen wie die
Sender rausgehen mit diesen Umfragen und
dann ist das erörtert worden und jetzt
will ich auch mal sagen das ist auch
meine Meinung das Wahlergebnis zwischen
Ziel und SPD liegt anderthalb Prozent
auseinander mehr nicht ich habe in
Nordrhein-Westfalen erlebt dass die CDU
stärkste Partei war und Frau Kraft eine
Regierung gebildet hat Mutter Null und
der Linkspartei gegen die stärkste
Partei ich habe erlebt dass das bei
anderthalb Prozent hinter armelasche
zurückgetreten hat dann im selben Abend
aber er kam dabei
2010 2010
in der deutschen Geschichte oft gehabt
dass Parteien die
46 47 Prozent der Stimmen bekommen haben
in Opposition saßen weil er ist sehr
lange so ging die FDP entscheidet wer in
diesem Land regiert ja Jahrzehnte so
gewesen so also deswegen würde ich mal
sagen dass eine zweitstärkste Partei
unter Umständen Kanzlerpartei wird ist
zumindest in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland nichts
außergewöhnt das ist aber nicht die
Situation nee also ich meine ich finde
sie müssen noch mal einräumen die
Zustimmung zu Laschet als Kanzler als
potenziellem Kanzler die ist also ich
habe eine Umfrage sind dabei die bei
neuen Prozent gegen Zustimmung für
Scholz von weiß ich nicht 46 Prozent das
war doch diese Situation und da finde
ich da kann man nicht sagen wir gehen
jetzt aber mit diesem Mann gehen wir
jetzt und verhandeln eine neue Regierung
mit beschlossen an der an dem Abend um
17 Uhr 30 es war ja gar nicht alleine
sondern man hat gesagt pass auf du gehst
jetzt raus du gratulierst nicht
du erkennst auch keine Niederlage also
gesagt worden wir werden uns nicht aus
den Spielen nehmen ist ja nicht gesagt
worden was sie jetzt noch eine
interpretieren ich wollte das nicht mal
sagen dass das keine alleinige
Entscheidung von Armin Laschet war dazu
gehört dass diejenige die heute im
Brasilien CDU Deutschland sind bei
dieser Meinungsfindung mit am Tisch
lassen
das nervt sie das dass ich jetzt alle in
die Büsche schlagen und der Laschet ist
das ist nicht in Ordnung wenn man wenn
man dabei ist das was sagt wir nehmen
uns jetzt nicht aus dem Spiel
formuliert das ist dann seine Sache ist
ja klar das was ich dazu zieht wenn man
nachher das Interview geben muss es sind
ja dieselben Menschen hinterher auch
dafür kritisiert haben das geht das sie
haben ja gemerkt dass nicht alle in
kritisiert haben ich bin Zeitzeuge
dieser Geschichte dass das impräsidium
ganz klar so
abgesprochen worden ist darüber ist
nicht abgestimmt worden aber wie man so
zusammen sitzt wie machen wir es jetzt
aber sie sehen es ja auch daran dass wir
sehr bewusst uns entschieden haben dass
der Generalsekretär und der
Parteivorsitzende nicht alleine auf der
Bühne standen sondern erinnern sich an
die Bilder das gesamte Parteipräsidium
stand auf dieser Bühne
unterschiedlich interessant
da sehen wir das Foto das heißt was war
mit allen abgestimmt was er da vorne
gemacht hat da es war nicht der Text
abgestimmt ist das aber die Idee sich im
Spielzeug im Spiel zu lassen ist eine
Entscheidung gewesen die wir dort in
dieser Runde getroffen haben und ich bin
auch nach wie vor der Meinung man kann
das anders sehen wie sie das jetzt
dargestellt haben dass das in dem Moment
auch eine richtige Entscheidung war ob
das jetzt drei Tage später doch die
richtige Entscheidung war weiß ich nicht
in der Politik ist es ja oft so das
waren sehr schnell was entscheiden muss
ich glaube nur dass die Menschen die
Union gewählt haben die so viel weniger
auch nicht sind wie die die SPD gewählt
haben auf jeden Fall nicht wollen dass
es in diesem Land eine Ampel gibt und
von ihrer Partei erwarten dass wir auch
zur Verfügung stehen eine Ampel zu
verhindern das glaube ich schon
so ich schaue mir gerade wenn sie da mal
drauf schauen auf die Köpfe die da
stehen das war alles so gesprochen dass
ich aber Leute alltours man sich zum
Beispiel da ich sehe Tobias Hans aus dem
Saarland
Spahn Röntgen speziell Brinkhaus es war
doch alles Leute die hinterher sehr
deutlich der Meinung waren das war der
falsche Weg und auch vorher schon der
Meinung waren das war der falsche Weg
ja weil man halt in so einem Moment
kopflos ist es ist das ist eben die
Situation die wir jetzt beobachten die
Union steht da ohne politische Führung
das ist ganz
eine ganz ungewohnte Situation und ich
glaube
sie haben in dem Punkt Recht das Laschet
nicht alleine verantwortlich ist weil
das was seinen Wahlkampf ausgezeichnet
hat nämlich dieses Orte das kriegen wir
schon und man hat eben lange gedacht
Annalena baerbock ist die hauptgegnerin
die verfrühstücken wer eben mal morgens
früh
diese Situation hatte man lange gehabt
und dann ist man plötzlich aufgebaut hat
gedacht oh moment mal wir müssen ja ein
sozialpolitischen Wahlkampf führen das
hat man dann viel zu spät gemerkt und
einfach und es zugeben der Union diese
Überzeugung in den Knochen die Leute
wählen uns sowieso das ist der meint da
bin ich der Meinung alle wie sie da
stehen waren von dieser Überzeugung
irgendwie so ein bisschen geprägt und
man aus der muss die Union wirklich mal
aufwachen da findet die politische
Vernichtung eines Menschen statt dass
man die Angriffe vom politischen Gegner
kriegt ist ja erstmal normal aber wie
man sie kriegt sie dann teilweise aus
den eigenen Reihen kommen das ist
schlicht und ergreifend ein Zustand der
wirklich schlimm ist Zitat Ende ja
das ist ja auch so ich muss sie ganz
ehrlich sagen ich habe in der Woche nach
der Bundestagswahl ging es mir richtig
schlecht weil
weil das einfach das Wahlergebnis geht
dann natürlich in die Knochen aber auch
die Art und Weise ist natürlich
nicht in Ordnung und man muss es ganz
klar so es geht vielleicht auch manchmal
in der Politik nicht anders auf jeden
Fall hat mir das das richtig zugesetzt
jetzt sage ich bin ich darüber weg jetzt
müssen wir sehen dass wir sind sie
enttäuscht von ihrer eigenen Partei nein
ich bin nicht von meiner Partei
enttäuscht das kann ich gar nicht von
den Leuten aber ich finde ich finde man
muss es so nicht machen es ist einfach
so dass ich finde wenn jemand jeder weiß
dass das Armin Laschet jetzt politisch
wenn man es mal so sagen darf doch am
Boden liegt und da muss man nicht mehr
nach treten das ist einfach eine Sache
wo ich sage dass das muss man doch nicht
machen und ich glaube einfach dass diese
Situation
nicht die Leute aus der eigenen Partei
ja gut also
einfach nicht lassen
diesen Spruch dass man immer sagt naja
gegenüber meinem politischen Gegner kann
ich mich schon selber wehren lieber Gott
Schütz mir vor meinen eigenen Freunden
das ist ja so ein Spruch den es ja
durchaus in der Politik gibt den ich
Gott sei Dank in meinem politischen
Leben so gut wie nicht erlebt habe das
muss ich auch mal sagen dass sehr viel
Glück gehabt aber die die Situation ist
jetzt wie sie ist jetzt
habe ich und viele andere sich gefangen
jetzt habe ich auch Spaß daran dass man
darauf achten muss dass der Neubeginn
die Neuaufstellung der CDU eine neue
Aufstellung wird wo die CDU eine
christliche Volkspartei der Mitte bleibt
aber Herr Laumann und wir müssen ja sie
haben eben gesagt der Bundestagswahl
wurde dann zum Schluss ein sozialbücher
Wahlkampf ich muss ihn ganz ehrlich
sagen wir haben kein sozialpolitischen
Wahlkampf als Union geführt